well Africa certainly has some very
particular development challenges I mean
there's an issue of governance which in
some African countries is is a very
serious problem Anderson issue in other
places of conflict so there are two kind
of underpinning things but there's also
been I suppose the problem with with
Africa the reason it's in the problem in
the difficulty that is is because it's
really a number of these countries are
really stuck in a poverty trap some of
that is due to the very you know
difficult environment they're working in
whether that's a physical environment
but which has a you know a burden of
disease like malaria and and other
problems but there's other problems of
sheer economic underdevelopment very
poor infrastructure in many parts of
Africa so again it's a matter of trying
to you know find ways of getting people
out of this poverty trap and onto the
development ladder and that has been
happening increasingly I mean it's wrong
to say that or for people to think that
Africa is is a basket pace case there
are many countries in Africa over the
past ten years that have been growing at
quite respectable rates five six seven
percent per annum and it's trying to
build on that while recognizing that
there are certain countries certain
problem areas where you know unless you
tackle issues like governance and
dealing with the conflict problem you
can't even start out on the road to
development and that is for example in
the case of the likes of Darfur and Chad
and at another level I mean particularly
particularly bad cases obviously
Zimbabwe
well clearly there needs to be political
change I mean that's the first and i
would say fundamental fundamental
requirement and i note that in recent
days President Bush is called for mr.
Mugabe to resign a number of other
leaders who have done the same and I
think that's an indispensable first step
if and hopefully when that happens then
there is a question of can be ghetto a
serious political settlement within the
country of people agreeing to work
together and then what needs to be done
is that you know a program of
rehabilitation to be put in place with
substantial international assistance but
you know I do think an indispensable
first step is for President Mugabe to
step down